we've got somebody else who's very good
at what they do few people ever reached
the status of living legend but
dolly parton is certainly a member of
that group the iconic entertainer
recently reached 3 billion that's with a
b
worldwide streams of her music she's had
hits on the country music chart seven
decades in a row you go miss dolly and
she's been nominated for 50 grammy
awards so far in her career now she's
cooking up something new with a
partnership with i love this one duncan
hines so you too can make dolly's
favorite cakes right in your own kitchen
first on cbs mornings we spoke with
dolly earlier about her newest project
and celebrating every single year
i've been known to trample little
children to get something with icing
i love cake and i love cupcakes so
thank you
well thank you for having me and welcome
to my kitchen first i want to get the
back story were you just a baker by
trade do you often go in the kitchen and
you're walking around baking things well
i love to cook and i learned to do that
growing up in the mountains of east
tennessee my mom was a great cook all my
aunts and my grandmas so of course i
learned to cook that good old southern
stuff and i love to eat and i love to
cook and i love to bake so we got
involved with duncan hines and we
thought this was a great partnership so
i'm excited about it and i really think
people are going to enjoy all these
recipes we know duncan hines is great
anyhow
i think so too listen i've been known to
eat duncan hines right out of the jar
but i'm on day two of an intermittent
fast and i can't eat for another two
hours so it's killing me just to look at
the cake but it looks really really
tasty so i thank you for this well thank
you i'm sorry about that are you going
to eat that cake won't you get it i
asked
i am i am but i'm going to eat it in my
allotted period i guess just got to say
this to you dolly people hold you in
such high regard i don't know anybody
anybody on the planet i mean this
sincerely that doesn't admire respect
you and really love you so much how does
that sit with you after all this time in
the career that you've had
well it's an honor but it scares me to
death sometimes i'm always saying i'm
not all that i'm even i'm even not all
there sometimes but it makes me feel
good that i've been around long enough
for people to feel like they know me and
they've just kind of accepted me and now
that i'm older they just kind of think
of me as like an older sister or
favorite aunt and i'm glad to play that
role and that's sweet of people to say
all those nice things about me so that's
nice i'll try to live up to it
listen you just celebrated a birthday
recently what kind of cake did you have
for your birthday
well of course i had a banana
flavored uh cream cake one of my own
because i love banana pudding a real
banana pudding so i thought why not bake
one of these duncan heinz cakes for my
birthday so i chose the banana one
and i was 76 years old so i i've been
cooking a long time
let's talk about turning 76. i love that
you just said that i love that you don't
run away from that you know are you at
the stage that you embrace every
birthday because there are some people
that get to the point where they don't
want to talk about their birthdays they
don't want to acknowledge their
birthdays and you still seem to be
grabbing life with such gusto to me
well i try not to think about the number
and i couldn't lie about it anyway
because i've been in show business all
my life everybody knows how old i am
every year uh so actually i don't i try
not to think about the numbers i i don't
feel old and i in my mind i remember my
life was in a great spot when i was 35
years old and i remember at that time
thinking this is a great time in my life
so i chose to just kind of think like
i'm 35 all the time in my mind no matter
how what the numbers say number numbers
lie
no i'm with you on that you know what
because i still see myself as 40
something i thought 40s were great but
you know as i sit here today i just
turned 67. i really do enjoy i i swear
to you i've enjoyed every single stage
of life did you have a certain favorite
time period in your life yeah that's
kind of when i was about 35 i remember
thinking i'm out of debt for the most
part you know and i can kind of relax a
little bit i don't have because i had
really done a lot of the things i had
worked so hard to do and that's i don't
think i slowed up at all until i was 35
and i just rested a minute and then i
went at it again so now i feel like i'm
in the i mean i wish i could be young
forever so i could do more things but
every year it seems like i do more
things and i feel like i've dreamed
myself into a corner because my dreams
have come true but i have to still be
responsible for them and every dream
kind of brings its own you know there's
a new life to that and then you just
kind of branch out and you have all
these opportunities and i'm not one to
let an opportunity to go to waste so
here i am even doing this you are
waiting for your cakes
happened to me dolly when i turned 40. i
realized you cannot please everybody so
you might as well try to please yourself
did you have an age where you thought i
know i can't please everybody
or are you still trying to please people
i try to please people although i've
always known i couldn't please everybody
but i try to please as many people as i
can but like you it's more important
that i please myself if i'm pleasing to
me i think that that will be pleasing to
other people as well i think people
sense it if you're comfortable in your
own skin and always make a joke and say
i'm comfortable in my own skin no matter
how far i've stretched it
so i try to look as good as i can and i
just try to
to be comfortable and you know just uh
just be myself and just i never think
like i'm a star i just think i'm a
working girl i always have i always say
that i'm a i'm a workhorse dressed up as
a show horse and that's really the truth
dolly you are certainly a light in
addition to you were talking about you
know doing as much as you can while
you're here so you've written a book
with james patterson
well go big or go
i have and it's a thriller it is it's
called run rose run and it's coming out
in march and i loved working with james
i've read everything he's ever written
and so when he asked if i'd write a book
with him i mean i i was shocked and i
said well now what do you want to write
it about and so we we chose the
nashville kind of a scene about a girl
that's running from her past but running
toward a future and so it's really got a
lot of twists and turns and we're going
to eventually make a movie out of it too
and i may even get to play one of the
parts one of the characters that's in
the book but i wrote a i thought how can
i contribute working with james
patterson who why does he need me but
anyhow when we started writing i thought
the best way i could contribute to it
was to write songs about these
characters and their situations so i
would send all the songs and then he
would expand on the characters and then
we'd get together he'd give me ideas for
songs and so we really had a great
working relationship and i was real real
happy with how it turned out
dolly thank you so much your latest
contribution is cake and i happen to
believe that everything is better with
icing on it so i thank you so much
oh thank you that butter butter cream is
good and this is good so let us eat cake
i say you can't go wrong with uh cake
and dolly parton she sent us a coconut
cake
does it seem like when i'm sitting over
there that i'm screaming at the tv
that's how it felt does it seem yeah
does it sound loud to you guys it's a
weird setup but you mentioned that she
sent cake to us i don't remember cake
have you had cake no gail where's the
kkk where's the cake oh my kitchen
counts
but i did ask her to send a banana one
so i'll make sure i share that because
sharing is caring yes but i love her
listen you know she's one of time 100's
most influential people and miley cyrus
who's her goddaughter wrote her intro
and she described her as the world's
most impeccably purposeful walking
contradiction
isn't that good that is i think that's
very she said i'm like i'm a workhorse
yes dressed up as a show horse i love it
i just consider myself as a working girl
one of my favorite people no plans to
stop the world me too